well it's not often many of us achieve
greatness at such a young age but that
is the case for 11 year old Superstar
twirler this is Annabella she's headed
to the international baton twirling
championships this summer her mom
Michelle ladies thank you for coming on
the show this morning you're up early
yeah yes but you told me during
commercial break you do often get up
this early to practice yes okay so let's
talk about it when did you start
twirling I I've been twirling my whole
life but I only started competing until
I was four only when she was four okay
and Mom you would mentioned that this is
actually a family event this is
something that you grew up doing that's
right so my mom was actually a baton
twirler so that's how I got started and
then I twirled my entire life and was
recruited to twirl at UNLV so I was the
future troller with the marching band at
UNLV wow and that's something that all
twirlers really aspire to do is to Twirl
in college so that is kind of the
Pinnacle but did you get to do any World
Championships no I was not fortunate
enough to have that opportunity so we're
so excited for Annabella to have that
opportunity I bet and this is you said
told me during commercial break this is
your first time out of the country are
you excited what kind of feelings do you
have about this I'm very nervous but I'm
also very excited because it's my first
time out of the country and I get to go
to a very big place for it's a great
honor well and you're representing not
only Nevada but the United States how
many other twirlers are representing the
U.S do you know in my category there's
only six from the United States but I'm
the only one from Nevada oh my goodness
what an honor uh okay now tell me
because of different routines you know a
lot of folks are very familiar with
gymnastics so when you're twirling you
have a baton but there's two different
styles of events that you can compete in
talk to me about those two well I'm
competing in extra in an extra you have
to keep the Baton intact with your hand
the whole time so you don't toss but you
do dance movements in an x pattern okay
minute time Max okay and in another
event solo you have to toss the Baton
spin around and catch it and try not to
drop it and they have two baton and
three baton and four baton no kidding
yeah okay and and so the event that
you're participating in it's staying on
your hand do you just hop One Baton yes
I have One Baton and your dance
movements Incorporated with some music
as well okay wow oh my goodness and you
have two sisters and they both twirl as
well yes they do so you guys have a
little fun together sometimes at the
house and play and practice okay what
kind of time commitment is this every
day almost every day in the summer time
we try to practice every single day okay
yes that's a lot but you love it I love
it okay Mom she loves it huh she does oh
I think she's naturally talented so well
that's a very hard worker as well I I
bet you're great in school too yeah yeah
it kind of goes hand in hand doesn't it
okay we are going to see Annabella
perform here in just a little bit so
stay with us we're gonna take a break
ladies hang tight I'll be right back